One small line in Avengers: Infinity War could
hold the key to understanding that shocking
ending.
And it's also a cool callback to 2016's standalone
Doctor Strange flick.
Warning: Major Infinity War spoilers ahead!
Doctor Strange's claim that he sees only one
of "14 million six hundred and five" possible
future scenarios in which the Avengers defeat
Thanos could help to explain some of his,
well, strange behavior in the movie's second
half.
Infinity War features the MCU's most powerful
heroes fighting to stop Thanos from attaining
five Infinity stones and wiping out half the
life in the universe.
However, their plan is thrown for a loop when
Doctor Strange gives Thanos the Time Stone
in exchange for him sparing Tony Stark's life.
The move appears to have been a fatal one
for Strange, who is wiped out after Thanos
gets the Mind Stone and carries out his plot.
But before he turns to dust, Strange tells
Stark that "there was no other way," which
suggests that giving up the stone is critical
to the Avengers' victory.
This could mean a few things.
It could suggest that Stark will have a key
part to play in defeating Thanos, and had
to be spared.
It could also mean that Thanos wiping out
half the life in the universe temporarily
is actually part of Strange's winning scenario,
which brings us to that subtle callback.
In the character's standalone film, Strange's
mentor the Ancient One tells him she can never
see past her own demise.
"I've spent so many years peering through
time, looking at this exact moment.
But I can't see past it."
She then adds:
"I've prevented countless terrible futures
and after each one there's always another,
and they all lead here but never further."
So if Doctor Strange is able to see beyond
the moment when he is apparently dusted by
Thanos, it means he didn't really expire,
and Thanos' handiwork won't last in the scenario
in which the Avengers win.
This supports the theory that the Avengers
are just stuck in the Soul World - a dimension
inside the Soul Stone where dead characters
sometimes go in the comics - and can be brought
back to life for Avengers 4.
It'll be awhile before we know for sure what's
up with the doc's enigmatic words, with Avengers
4 not slated to hit theaters until May 3rd,
2019.
But for now, he's definitely given Marvel
fans something strange - and hopeful - to
think about.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!